hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander we're gonna be reviewing the
trailer today the second one i am behind
on this one and with my business on
youtube
behind means i'm two days late yeah
basically this trailer got released for
san andreas earthquake film I believe
starring Dwayne the rock Johnson we're
doing the rock Johnson's gonna punch an
earthquake you guys just hit this next
part to go straight to the trailer but I
wanted to give a shout out David a duck
be known no no I'm definitely this David
Duffy no nay I love the real rejects he
loves us so much we spelled it are tal
you guys are awesome you cracked me up
every time I watch your videos
especially you mr. right ah well dude
this looks like a scary photo of you
yeah I don't know are you an actor or a
cosplayer
what I see is a black guy with blue eyes
you kind of look like an alien see them
I'm not gonna lie he looks like an alien
but like a cool I guess that's awful
have you seen the first men in black
remember how there was the farmer and
then he got taken by the cockroach and
then the cockroach went inside his skin
and now he was like a healing cockroach
that was the villain played by Vincent
Dee in the fornum de for Nia I forgot I
was like anyway that's what he looks
like he looks like an alien has
inhabited his body and his skin is a
little bit I'm just [ __ ] with you I
um I I run out of ideas for shoutouts so
I just resort to insulting you keep it
up you're black so that automatically
means you have a huge wing and dangling
use it that will be your new superpower
mm-hmm the power of the [ __ ] respect the
[ __ ] respect look look
[Music]
a hair makeup looks great for just being
in a disaster
[Music]
[Music]
are you hurt
are you hurt people need to know that
the shaking is not will it'll get hit
again and it's going to be a bigger
monster
that was moving on its girlfriend I will
literally crack open and you will feel
it an East Coast
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
there-there gives the rock
[Music]
I must admit I do have chills yeah I
mean it seemed kind of cheesy but the
effects kind of like destroyed that
anyway it did I feel like that's gonna
be insane yeah yeah real fast um I like
to do this when to establish how real
the chills are you can see my nipple
through my shirt right now I don't know
if you can actually but it's pretty
erect you guys see it's right there
erect nipples that's what happens when I
get chills something else right oh I
just hope it's not like 2012 where it
ends this looks exactly like roland
emmerich did 2012 and the day after
tomorrow and Independence Day and this
looks like all that but takes place in
California which is great because then I
can relate this movie's gonna be very
powerful for this one state
it's not gonna be worldwide appeal while
I did get chills at the same time I'm
like this looks like it's gonna be like
very unrealistic and stuff the opening
sequence I was like that would not I'm
like effects look cool buildings falling
over you don't know how fast a
helicopter is and how great of a [ __ ]
pilot he can be to like drive the
helicopter save this woman from the
crowd and get away from villain it
seemed like it was a random woman and I
was like wait why would they go out of
the way if it was just a random woman
like I thought maybe he knew her which
is why they went maybe all that trouble
but it would seem a little far-fetched
for him to go through all of that
trouble just to save one woman Dwayne
Johnson saw her and he was like I'm
gonna show her my Johnson following [ __ ]
not falling falling sorry here can you
joke all right so when Dwayne Johnson
saw carla Gugino he was like I'm gonna
show her my joke you know it's not funny
or the second time you run the jokes I
like I'm sorry the effects I feel like
is gonna make this movie really great
but other than that I don't really know
I'm hoping it's just sure entertainment
yeah this trailer looks like it's very
serious
hmm like this looks like a horrifying
disaster but at the same time I'm like
distracted by so many unrealistic things
and kind of the cheesiest occurs when
there was like that much about I pauses
like on the East Coast
yeah they got their typical lines of
like Oh something Bad's happening yeah
but everyone's like yeah it's just
happening here and then you got that one
character who's like looking across the
globe it's all gonna go everywhere now
yeah I mean the boat like going towards
the way what it what are they trying to
do to stop the damn wave I don't see I
don't know but the rock will get through
the way while the boats into his left
and right will be flipping over I'll
trust the rock and I will definitely see
this movie though I'm really interested
I like how that one boat when flipping
yeah yeah he was like no my part of the
waters gonna be okay let's jet through
this like that sucks for ya yeah we'll
be fine
ah yeah I know the waters Alexandra
Daddario is in it
he's [ __ ] hot look at her man she's
[ __ ] gorgeous she has amazing tit and
she has amazing eyes eyes are cool too
she is really hot I guess I'm just
jealous you're probably I would totally
slow down the video of her I'm just
jealous of the fact that like why is she
dating Logan Lerman like why can't I do
look a lemon I don't
well her her eyes are more Boldin and
its color and her tits are bigger she's
tall I mean you're person so actually my
proportions if I were as tall as her I'd
probably have the same proportion yeah
well you're playing the if game and
reality boobs for a tiny butt and that's
true but in reality there's a reason why
low
okay look we're getting off topic using
we're getting off topic bottom line this
movie has to be one simple thing
entertainment has to have bomb effects
the rock has to give his intense
performance some science [ __ ] that
everyone's gonna [ __ ] disprove
there's gonna be a lot of unrealistic
moments but if it if it knows what it is
you know instead of trying to the
problem with movies like this is when
they take themselves so seriously that
it's unintentionally bad yeah if it's a
self-aware film in some aspects where
they know like okay this is ridiculous
this is cheesy but they commit to it it
could really work I just hope that it's
kind of gonna be more on the twister
side like twister is a really good
disaster movie because it focuses on
just a couple people and it's not too
far-fetched
it is really okay it seemed really
realistic I hope that this one just kind
of keeps it more simple than trying to
do this whole like worldwide catastrophe
and just get lost yeah because the
problem with these movies it's cut it's
kind of weird like I think of like news
reports in a way like you might hear
like a giant bomb exploding and killing
a lot of people but if you hear about
like one person being murdered
it seems more impactful for some reason
because it's more personal yeah and no
like one family was directly influenced
alright yeah affected and there's a
bunch of people it's kind of oh it's a
number at that point for some reason I'm
not saying I'm like heartless no I get
what you're saying and and that's the
problem with it with what I see from
this trailer is it's so epic in its
scope but I'm like we've become immune
to that in movies like that becomes you
know just great visuals but I don't
really care about a lot of people that
are dying most people we care about then
it makes it all the more real for yeah
that makes some more intense when you
give it a more personal story so this is
the second trailer and we still haven't
gotten that so I'm hoping that the rock
is more of a character than just someone
who's intense trying to [ __ ] eat the
road yeah trying to sleep the world this
pilots gonna say anyway guys if you
needed the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects yeah and salamander
Sally has a channel too has a lot of fun
[ __ ] on there
you should check that now some more
coming soon so subscribe yeah do that
and you can follow us on Instagram
Twitter and Facebook if you have a hard
time remembering just call fit Facebook
Instagram Twitter tip you call TIFF and
yeah and then pics is my porn acronym
it's pyx pornhub.com uu porn calm and
xvideos calm pics fit pics so after you
check us out on fit if you want to relax
you go to pics I hope people remember
this it'll be in the description box you
know they say when Dwayne Johnson gets
an erection yeah